man, I can't believe we're back
we're gonna be back I mean it's right
we're gonna be back
welcome back everyone it's Charlie this
is going to be my new Rick and Morty season
4 trailer video for the back half of the
season they released a new mr. poopy
butth*le promo to fill in the gap
between the first half of season 4 in
the second half so if you're brand new
to the channel be sure to subscribe to
get all the videos I will keep doing
bonus videos for the series while we
wait for episodes to come back and we
are still doing that merch giveaway all
you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave your favorite
moment from the season on the video so
as they've done in the past they use
this character to sort of tag the end of
a block of episodes in between seasons
even though technically it's the back
half of season 4 it's not like we're
going from season 4 episode 5 to season
they'll be episodes 6 through 10 next
year but starting with season 3 they
started to get really crazy and meta
with it releasing these kinds of
trailers to fill in the gaps in his
timeline between seasons where isn't a
traditional series you would actually
expect to get this backstory through
some exposition in an actual episode
like a season 4 episode 3 he just shows
up as a professor teaching a lecture
course so either he's an alternate
version or he just got his PhD really
fast after he got his GED as he calls it
in that season three post credits scene
this one is really just for the
Christmas holiday this week but it's mr.
poopy butth*le going on vacation with
his wife and son at a cabin and Rick
portaling in to check on him and then
leave the cabin is supposed to be a
reference to the same cabin that Rick's
family went to hide out at in the
wilderness when trying to get away from
Rick at the end of season 3 that was
really just because they were afraid
that he was going to get rid of Beth
because she still wasn't a hundred
percent on whether or not she was a
clone I know there's still a lot of
theories out there about that even Dan
Harmon still likes to tease people about
that that's a clown just to be clear
that's not him confirming that Beth is a
clone that just him having a little bit
of fun with the people that are filming
this interview that they had at Comic
Con but the other clip is him just
looking at his scrapbook filling in the
gaps in his timeline between the season
two post-credit scene in the season 3
post credits scene like where did his
kid come from how did he meet his wife
what's going on here so they give you
all this extra backstory showing him at
all these different locations during the
season three episodes through his
timeline as he slowly meets his wife
like you flash back to him when he was
Morty's age in a class where he met his
version of Jessica it's even like a mrs.
poopy butth*le designed
look kind of like a Jessica then they're
a little bit older still studying in
school but they're sitting on a bench
from Cronenberg world made up of a whole
bunch of different people just going
back to that planet then they graduate
high school they get their GEDs like he
said in the season three post-credit
scene just as it looks like the Galactic
government is taking over their world at
the end of season two then they're just
a little bit older they have the same
rebellion arc in the background as you
see season 3 episode 1 the Galactic
government leaving earth then they visit
the same detoxification spa from season
3 episode 6 and it seems like they had
the same fight with their toxic selves
make all the theories you want about
what parts of mister poopy butth*le you
think for toxic probably the part that
took all those pills because when he
comes back he's not on the pills anymore
this is them during the events of season
3 episode 3 you see Jaguar in the
background getting ready to jump out of
a plane then they're a little bit older
they're continuing their courtship with
a picnic in the park while they're being
watched from the bushes by one of the
aliens from season 3 episode 9 that
Jerry was hunting with Chiara then
there's a version of his proposal that
matches exactly Morty's memory-foam
Morty's mind blowers that Rick had to
erase I saw a lot of people after that
split on what Morty's memory of this
meant a lot of people thought that he
was just helping him practice his
proposal the other half thought that it
really did mean he was proposing to
Morty who then said yes and had to have
his memory wiped
because it would be complete disaster
for Rick and he didn't want have any
part of that nonsense they get married
they reveal that he's canonically Jewess
she's being married by the rabbi that
you see pop up in regular Rick and Morty
episodes or his wife was and he
converted to her religion then it seems
like him moving them into a different
apartment within the complex of
apartments that he lives in because the
apartment is almost the exact same but
there was no dining room in the season
two apartment he was living in then
there's this whole montage of him
scrapbooking his pets like they're
people in this relationship that runs
its own full arc from friendship to the
death of the cat there's even a plum bus
here in the background
everyone is so sad that the cat is dying
he can't help it but wait within what
looks like minutes of him grieving his
wife is telling him she's pregnant with
their son looking at the ultrasound here
I guess we learned Easter egg that the
poopy butth*le species grow their top
hats in the womb so it's part of their
body if you're super big Nintendo fan
that's sort of like the Joe
about toads head what's going on is he
wearing a hat is that mushroom sitting
on his head or is that actually part of
his head and if you weren't sure that
actually is part of his head that is not
a hat that he wears you kind of have to
assume that his species or the culture
behind his race is toilet based so the
poopy butth*le name has some logic in
there reality this is just meant to be
the baby shower this is her doing that
Beyonce posed from that post a couple
years ago if you don't remember if she
got pregnant with her first child with
jay-z they did this whole big baby
reveal thing because there's the birth
of their son then he looks up at the sky
thinking a higher power for his good
fortune just because he was in such a
terrible place after season two addicted
to all those pills there been a lot of
people that have wondered if his
character is just going around on
adventures with an alternate version of
Rick that's not c-137 Rick and that's
how they explained the way they use him
in episodes making you wonder if he's
real or not real is this all happening
is this imaginary he is a confirmed real
character but the way the writers were
using him when he showed up during
season two was to Gaslight you the
audience because the whole episode was
about gas lighting like wait a minute
what's real what's fake what's just
these parasites making me think that all
this stuff happened showing you he's
real at the end of the episode but for
some strange reason Beth doesn't have
any pictures of him even though he's
been hanging out with their family this
whole time so the easiest way to explain
that is that he's just going around with
an alternate version of Rick that's not
c-137 Rick you could also just chalk
that up to Beth being kind of an asshole
and not thinking about mr. poopy
butth*le because if she's not going to put
Jerry's number in her phone and they're
married then why would she have pictures
of a bunch of other people hi you went
directly to voicemail because your
number is not in my phone don't leave a
message but everyone let me know if you
spotted any big Easter eggs and these
holiday promos that I didn't mention in
the video and I'll keep doing bonus
videos as they release more promos for
the back half of season 4 or if we get
any big news about when episodes are
actually coming back
congratulations Matthew Williams you're
the giveaway winner from my last big
Rick & Morty video please email me on
the about page of my channel so I can
get your details, everyone click here for my season 4 episode 5 video
and click here for my Rick and Morty season 4 episode 6 trailer video
thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome Happy Holidays!